[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao a tutti anch'io sono una laureata
iulm molto emozionata e felice di essere
di essere qui oggi a parlare di turismo
altro che pugni in faccia ha preso il
turismo 90 per cento della popolazione
mondiale improvvisamente si è fermato
completamente fermando un'industria
fondamentale per il mondo anche per
l'italia nel mondo rappresentava prima
dei covi di 10 per cento del pil un
occupato su quattro e la cosa è anche
importante che gli occupati nel campo
del turismo sono per la maggioranza
donne giovani e sono anche della minore
delle minoranze e questo ci dice che
impatto ha potuto avere lo stop nel
mondo della pandemia per l'italia il
turismo rappresentava il 13 per cento
del nostro pil e oltre 4 milioni di
occupati
quindi pugni in faccia
come si dice bisogna cogliere le
opportunità anche perché il turismo
se voi andate a vedere i dati
dell'organizzazione mondiale del turismo
vi mostrano come non ci sia mai stato
uno stop non c'è stato niente nelle
torri gemelle anche la crisi finanziaria
soltanto parzialmente bloccato questa
incredibile salita e crescita e quando
si cresce si pensa che tutto funziona al
meglio non ci si pone la domanda sto
sbagliando qualcosa certamente si
parlava di over turism si parlava di
alcuni fenomeni del turismo di massa
però la crescita di fatto non ci ha
messo mai nella situazione di ripensare
un modello e quindi in questo momento è
vero che si operano aprono un sacco di
opportunità soprattutto per voi che
inizierete a ragionare sua
imprenditorialità in vari campi non c'è
settore come quello del turismo dove ci
sono tantissime opportunità e tantissimi
trend da cogliere ve ne racconto alcuni
che possono essere credo di ispirazione
per voi
il primo trend è quello legato al tema
della sostenibilità dell'inclusione
della diversità ci siamo abbastanza
compiti la bocca prima del della
pandemia di queste tre parole
soprattutto il tema della sostenibilità
ma come dicevo con la crescita nessuno
ha pensato di fermare la crescita
ragionando in termini di sviluppo
sostenibile
in realtà questi sono dei valori che
oggi vengono reputati dai viaggiatori
come fondamentali e determinano anche le
scelte dei viaggiatori oggi per cui non
ci può essere oggi impresa né ambito
turistico che non abbia una sensibilità
su queste tematiche
una seconda tendenza molto importante
che durerà probabilmente è qui per
restare il tema della prossimità e della
familiarità cioè il fatto di essere
stati chiusi in una spazi ristretti di
aver potuto viaggiare poco ci ha fatto
tornare alla l'importanza dei valori
della famiglia e degli amici quindi si
viaggerà con gruppi piccoli familiari
non avremo più i gruppi che comunque
vedevamo prima nei pullman prima è anche
il tema della prossimità cioè ci piacerà
a viaggiare comunque conoscere se non
andare troppo distanti da dove da dove
abitiamo comunque stare in contesti
appunto di
amicizia e di raccoglimento questo è un
altro un altro elemento importante
perché nella vacanza in effetti si
riscoprono anche questo questo tipo di
valore il tema un altro tema
fondamentale è la digitalizzazione
naturalmente nel turismo è stata
fondamentale ma non colta fino in fondo
diciamo che la pandemia ci ha portato a
una penetrazione del livello di
digitalizzazione su tutti i livelli
della
società e delle popolazioni
siamo capaci di intercettarlo per
esempio oggi grazie big data
e qui c'è tutto un ambito di limi molto
importante di analisi e ricerca
riusciamo a capire la customer giorni
cosa vogliono dal momento
dell'ispirazione fino al momento della
posta esperienza i viaggiatori e questa
è una cosa fondamentale per imparare a
intercettarne appunto e intercettare
come dire il turista in tutta la
customer gironi e quindi questo è un
elemento estremamente importante
pensiamo poi alla tutte le tecnologie
contactless touchless che sono
fondamentali oggi soprattutto e questo è
un altro punto sul tema della sicurezza
perché oggi i turisti cercano sicurezza
soprattutto sanitaria ma non solo e
quindi grazie a queste tecnologie sia in
grado in effetti di intercettare questo
questa questa esigenza nuova ultimo
elemento non ininfluente il tema degli
spazi aperti dell'outdoor no siamo stati
chiusi
cioè un'esplosione di start up a livello
internazionale ma anche italiano legate
a la fruizione degli spazi aperti e
questo è un elemento quindi l'outdoor la
passione che si può esercitare
all'aperto gli sport ma non solo
e in questo senso ci sono veramente
tanti spazi di crescita per le aziende
veniamo dunque ai nuovi paradigmi
io ho studiato letteratura qui mi piace
richiamare
alcuni alcuni riferimenti che che mia mi
ha lasciato il mio studio penso a blaise
pascal la grande filosofo francese cosa
ci ci disse in uno dei suoi pensieri che
uno dei ma le orde dom
quindi uno delle disgrazie dell'uomo di
non sapere stare in una stanza a riposo
da solo
ecco noi abbiamo dovuto fare questo
sforzo straordinario durante la pandemia
e credo che mai come
in questo anno ci siamo resi conto di
come siamo
adattabili e di come comunque forse
nella riflessione nel stare da soli in
casa
a riposo siamo riusciti anche a tirare
risorse pensieri opportunità
in questo senso
mi viene in mente un altro bellissimo
libro coletto perché devo dire per me la
pandemia è stato un momento di non tanto
di serie a trovati molta lettura ho
letto un bellissimo libro che si chiama
il 100 man a mosca e racconta la storia
di un aristocratico
russo che si vede costretto costretto
dopo la rivoluzione a restare chiuso
all'hotel metropol per tutta la sua vita
pena decapitazione ecco questa la storia
di quest'uomo all'interno straordinario
all'interno alto colto un gran
viaggiatore come molti aristocratici
russi dell'epoca si trovava a ri per
rifondare la propria vita su una
all'interno di una camera all'interno di
una duna albergo per tutta la sua vita
etro e ne troverà tantissimi spunti con
curiosità con la curiosità che comunque
credo che sia uno degli elementi
fondamentali ed a tratti a da ad
attività che noi dobbiamo dobbiamo avere
quindi quali sono due tipologie di
viaggiatori che oggi stanno emergendo da
questi trend che vi o che vi ho appena
accennato prima di tutto staycation
working holiday che cosa significa
stiamo vedendo sul mercato immobiliare
che c'è un fenomeno di di urbanizzazione
quindi tantissime persone scelgono di
non abitare più in città ma di vivere
all'esterno proprio per godere di spazi
verdi proprio per meglio conciliare
anche la propria vita lavorativa con la
propria vita affettiva anche questo è un
nuovo paradigma quindi cosa su cosa sono
le walking holidays le staycation sono
anche andare invece di vivere in città
vivere nella propria seconda casa e
lavorare da lì e diventare turista può
guardare con altri occhi anche luoghi
conosciuti facendo dei brevi viaggi di
prossimità e quindi questo è uno dei
nuovi paradigmi che sicuramente vedremo
sempre di più a fermarsi
nella anche in ambito turistico
l'altra l'altro modello ha sempre a che
fare col cambiare la propria residenza
ma è è più legato al continuare a
cambiare noi da un altro modello proprio
è anche fatto di altre sensibilità e
sono è il nomadismo digitale le persone
scelgono di spostarsi continuamente per
brevi periodi
continuando a lavorare ma andando a
conoscere nuovi luoghi nuove persone
nuove culture e anche questo è qualcosa
che di cui è come dire credo tutti noi
siamo siamo circondati di esempi oggi
ecco io credo che questi
modelli working holiday e nomadismo
digitale siano molto utili per capire
come possono essere intercettate delle
tendenze importanti nel nel turismo di
oggi e credo che però la sfida più
importante che tutti dobbiamo affrontare
e soprattutto voi è quella di combinare
e di cogliere questa opportunità per
combinare la crescita con la
sostenibilità ambientale e sociale
dobbiamo vincere questa sfida dobbiamo
vincere sicuramente tutti insieme
sicuramente con voi grazie
[Applauso]